a big mistake women make is like women
go to advice about men to their
girlfriends go to advice about men to
your guy friends and also don't go to
your single girlfriends for advice about
being in relationships go to your
married friends yeah well I mean all of
your single friends want tequila
Tuesdays to keep happening which means
that that you know even if they're not
aware of it and even if they're
fantastic friends there is a part of
them that thinks it's kind of like
there's this idea in uh the black pill
incel world of ascending and ascending
is um becom a viable mate for women and
maybe maybe even getting into a
relationship and it's very heavily
discouraged because if one of the guys
within a group that are supposed to be
genetic dead ends that have no hope does
do something that creates a pain of oh
well this could happen to me and as soon
as you be believe that this could happen
to me maybe the reason it's not
happening to you is your fault maybe
it's not determined already and it's
kind of the same with the Singleton
thing like if you're going to go and ask
for advice about intimacy with someone
who never really seems to be intimate
with anyone they're going to first off
not have a a particularly fantastic
perspective I don't think unless they're
unbelievably incisive but secondly
there's going to be a little bit of a
perverse incentive that they don't want
their friend to start to pull away from
them uh oh so interesting I'm going to
give you the advice that makes what I'm
doing seem like a good idea and also
keeps you as a compatriot so that we can
both continue to do this together you
know we The Sisterhood like you know
girl you don't need him Etc ET it's like
well maybe maybe that is yeah maybe
that's maybe that's true but like if you
are unable guy or girl is anable to get
yourself a partner or enable to find
friends like no dude you don't need that
friend anymore it's like the subtext of
that is you can hang out with me I'm
your people when I was um I don't know
gosh I was probably my late 20s and I
dated a and I I'm only saying what he
does for a living because it might make
people like um it'll make make you
understand why I took it so uh well
professional athlete great at what he
does I just think a lot of times
professional athletes they don't they
can't there's not a lot of room for
emotion to be involved it's either true
or it's not true or you're going to get
your neck broken you know and he you
know dated a lot of you know could date
whoever he wanted or sleep with whoever
you wanted and I REM I was just in my
arrogance and in my like you know we
were like arguing about something and I
was like well like why would you date me
if like I'm the person you date if you
want like a
challenge and he just went why would any
man want a challenge in their
relationship and it was like I was like
thank you so much for saying that cuz I
guess I grew up watching parents fights
watching conflict is love conflict is
love I guess that's what I saw I guess I
thought it was sexy I guess I thought
men passion is yes I don't know what I
was thinking and I literally in that
moment was like oh my God I'm so like I
don't know what I I thought it was like
hot to you I thought it was like what
guys wanted I thought it was like feisty
like you know I apologize well
especially if you're dating somebody
that is high performing in any realm has
goals you know if you're working that
hard in the office you really want to
come home and be like right there's that
to-do list done I wonder what fires I
need to fight when I step through the
front door as well and now I'm kind of
at this point where it's like I'm good
at business I'm really good at what I do
I love the idea of being with the man
where I can be like how can I help you
make your like how can I be your
business partner like your silent
business partner whether it's like I can
have dinner waiting for you I can The
Rock Johnson probably needs a second one
of those I mean look I this so crazy to
me yeah they probably I want do I mean
State of California woman though she
gets half for after 10 years in a day
strange if you even with a prenup oh
that's a good question I don't know
you'd be surprised how few people have
prenups I mean remember he's got that
[__] whatever it is what's his is it
rum emotional support oh uh his rum
brand it's like tea or Rum or something
and uh I mean he's I heard he might warn
for office too I'd vote for him you know
because that's another thing is like
like I'm into that ride or die how can I
make your dreams come true like that's
I've made my dreams come true like it's
I'm into that Kink of like how could I
make your dreams come true like can I
being in service is is cool especially
if it's and this is something that we
spoke about before as well like not
doing it coming from a place of
desperation I want to make your dreams
come true or make your life better
because I think it'll make you love me
but there's almost something
extra sexy or seductive about somebody
putting their nature especially their
public facing nature to one side in
order to do something that seems
opposite or different to that privately
because it it seems like the love that
you have for me is causing it's so
strong that you're having to overcome
something that you do publicly you know
it's the same reason why the
high-powered male lawyer wants to be
tied up and and spanked by the
dominatrix right it's it's the PO
polarity of the life that makes it
interesting yes and that's the
difference between coming at it from a
place of desperation and weakness like I
want to do this because I think it's the
only way that you love me versus I am
fine on my own and I'm okay with being
independent and I have all of this stuff
going for me and I still want to you
know be the Homemaker build a family do
the whatever and it's the same for
that's why like the uh Chad to Dad
pipeline is so alluring I think to women
it's why so many stories all of the dark
romance novels are about a man who has
everything who is completely independent
and ruthless and and domineering and
prestigious and is softened over time by
the right woman because his love for her
pulls him in and it's the same as a
beautiful friendship story right there
is a friend who who struggles to connect
but you see something in them that's
amazing and then you become friends
together and you do you know the
Michelangelo effect do you know what
this is [__] brilliant so um it's a
psychological effect that describes how
over time two people often in a
relationship will craft each other into
the idealized version of what they want
so I make you more like what I want and
you make me more like what you want and
I am happy to become more like what you
want and you are happy and the reason
it's called the Michelangelo effect is
you can imagine Michelangelo looking at
this huge block of marble and from the
outside it's Ru Hune but over time he
chips away and creates the statue of
David so he sees inside of something
which isn't perfect the Perfection that
he wants and over time is able to craft
this thing out of it this is something
that's making me think of of something I
think that actually would be helpful to
people and is I feel like when you're in
a relationship with somebody and there's
things that you want to change about the
there's this new thing now where you
just can criticize your man or criticize
your person or someone comes home and
it's like yeah so you're just going to
walk walk in the door and not say hi and
da da da and this is where the you know
my having more intimacy and
relationships with animals than humans
actually comes in handy where positive
reinforcement is pretty much I believe
the only thing that works and I think
that I'm not seeing it on either side
right now with men or women so if like
your girl comes home and she's rough or
she's going out with her friends too
whatever it is just experiment with like
just say instead of getting in a fight
about it like just you know what I love
like I love when you come home I come
home and you're here here and you're
like on the couch and you're Barefoot
it's just the sexiest thing in the world
to me when I like come home and you're
here you know and like kiss her on the
forehead and just see if anything Chang
same thing with my girlfriends you're
like and I just told him that he needed
a and I'm like are you insane you can't
talk to people like that you know this
isn't like you're not in a fight on the
[__] Subway this is your man just
tell him like you know what I love it so
much when you like would I don't like
that he wears this thing when he wears
the other thing just tell him how hot it
is and suck his dick what why is this so
hard to understand and I you can't wear
those [__] Crocs around when he wears
the other shoes just suck his dick and
tell them how much you love the shoes
and kiss them and it's over you know so
I just think that we're not doing enough
positive reinforcement I think maybe
it's this like perfectionism generation
or maybe we're all standing up for
ourselves and I'm going to make a
boundary and I'm going to tell you all
the things that I don't like because I'm
going to be authentic and d d omissions
are not lies you know I just think that
for every criticism we have it's just
like like just try positive
reinforcement try that you know what I
love I love when your phone is off and I
just get to like we just get as opposed
to why do you always have your phone out
on the table it always makes me so
annoyed that's it don't even say that
one just when there's no phone out take
that opportunity to tell them how great
it is like this to me is about like
that's what it means to be soft I think
to just like bite your tongue shut your
[__] mouth you don't have to just be
roasting your man all the time I mean I
see it and there's certain rules to me
that I live by in relationships now it
took me a while to learn but you never
gossip about your man ever ever if
there's a a texting with some other girl
you don't I'm like you don't tell any of
your girlfriends you take it to a
therapist you take it to a 12-step
meeting like don't ever gossip about
your person don't ever make fun of your
person in public I see people a lot like
that women that don't understand why
relationships aren't working and then
you go out on a double dat and like cuz
he [__] can't get and you're just
like what the [__] are you doing like
you're embarrassing your man in front of
a bunch of people you know and so I see
this stuff and as someone who's a female
comic you would think that you know
that's that's not how I am in
relationships in the slightest and I
think that we're just like getting a
little too comfortable you know I did
this movie that was about it was based
on a book called the female brain and I
met with this female neuroscientist and
I said to her I was just like what's the
main advice you have for me like if I
leave here knowing one thing today about
the difference between the male and the
female brain and she just went your
girlfriend is not your
boyfriend what do you mean by that don't
treat them the same so if you want to
talk about how ugly the bridesmaid's
dresses were at Marcy's wedding call
your friend Lydia don't call your
boyfriend about it you know just like be
a little more cautious about the stuff
that you because then you come home and
you're like can you believe what
happened at work and this she was
wearing this blouse and the guy's just
like you know what I mean it's like well
you don't listen to me how come you're
not paying attention you don't want to
hear me talk it's like this isn't a
subject dud you're boring you're [__]
boring dude call your girlfriend so it's
like to me it's always a big red flag
when girls don't have girlfriends cuz
that means you're going to have to hear
all the boring ass [__] so like girls
know what to take to your girlfriends
and know what to take to your guy
friends or to your boyfriend you know I
think that's a really important thing
that a lot of girls don't do they expect
their boyfriend to be their girlfriend
you're not going to come to [__]
Nordstrom with me and hold my purse
while I change that's not the man that's
not my guy you know and don't make your
guy do [__] like that you know I just I
just think that like you know little
things like that I think make a really
big difference and if you are doing that
chances are you might not respect the
person and that's not the person for you
and I think people really forget about
respect it's like I'm attracted to him
and he's smart and he has this but do
you respect him cuz if you're going I
want you to spend your Saturday sitting
on a [__] velvet puff at Nordstrom
while I try [__] on unless it's like a
fun Kakey sex game that's a different
thing but like that's not respect you
don't respect your man's time yeah
that's again the pliability thing and
that's why having boundaries is so
important this episode is brought to you
by short form short form is my absolute
favorite way to discover new non-fiction
books and gain deeper insights into
books that I've already read you guys
know about how important my reading list
is to me and short form is an easier
faster and cheaper way to dive into
ideas that I've always been curious
about they're essentially book summaries
on steroids they provide super detailed
Guides of the book's key ideas and
they've got smart insights and
interactive exercises I really love
using short form to revisit some of my
all-time favorite books like the 48 Laws
of Power by Robert Green they've got
onepage summaries and breakdowns of each
chapter that will help you to better
absorb and solidify all of the learnings
without having to go back through a book
that you've already read the best part
is that they always keep their Library
fresh short form drops new book guides
and articles every week and subscribers
get to vote on what books to cover you
can try shortform completely free for 5
days with no obligation by following the
link in the description or by going to
short form.com modern wisdom and you'll
get an additional 20% off if you sign up
for the annual subscription that's
short.com
slod wisdom what's happening people if
you enjoyed that then press here for the
full unedited episode and don't forget
to
subscribe